jordan lyles gets ready to work against
one of his former clubs the right-hander
born in hartsville south carolina makes
his home now in the denver area he gets
christian to two strikes two and two the
count on the padres lead off man and
there's one down the middle strike three
called on grisham one away and
interesting right there to see jordan
lyles we have a tendency to focus on the
fastball in the curveball good way to
get this one started for lyles he had
bat fernando tatis junior
[Applause]
goes fastball and he gets him looking
gone for a guy that's been crushing it
this year to take that fastball looking
certainly a good nod to jordan lyles and
how good that pitch was the mound is
zach davies if zach davies can produce
like he did his last two starts he's
going to be a-okay
davies changes davies just keep it going
it's todd frazier scoreless two out
nobody ought
made him go after one right in the dirt
that same change was just diving diving
to his feet a swing at a miss right
three that's the kind of stuff we've
seen in every single start now of this
is number five for zach davies first and
second nobody out jake cronin we're
standing in for san diego
in the air down the left field line
shinsu headed over towards the corner
and that ball is going to land fair it
kicks away nasty ricochet as coming
around as hosmer to score
to third goes france on a double by jake
cronenworth and the padres strike first
on top one to nothing
and the padres score first so now it is
second and third a run in nobody out and
jerks and profile coming up with a
chance to really add some more runs
this one is lined towards left center
field and that's a gapper it gets down
hoping to cut it off is two france will
score cronenworth behind him will score
it is a two-run double for jerks and pro
farm the padres take a three-nothing
lead a good start to this one in texas
tonight jerks and takes a pitch outer
third it just serves it that way hey you
get to him early and jordan lyles might
be texas toast
eight hitter
josh naylor line drives center field
that's a base hit charging in center
solak up and throwing and that'll be cut
scoring his profile how about them boys
four nothing the san diego padres as
trent grisham comes up to the play the
seventh member of the padres about here
in the second inning in this fast start
tonight
this one is lined to center field and
that one's going to get in for a base
hit coming around from second base is
nail or the throw is cut off and the
padres have a five-nothing lead trent
grisham drives in a run all san diego so
far in this one they've got delisles for
five runs here in the second inning so
far wow this is unbelievable two outs
osmond first down here is jake
cronenworth
this one is chopped up the middle
bare-handed and frazier can't get it
there gets away up the right field line
still running his hosmer hosmer's going
to try and score here comes the throw he
will be safe
just got in and the padres take a
six-nothing lead well going with the
bare hand which isn't a bad play and
then sliding toward yet nice slide by
eric going on the foul side of home
plate that ball was very catchable in
first base procedure fourth inning
austin hedges
this one is in the air to deep left
center field back goes to center fielder
solac onto the track at the wall ball is
gone home run austin hedges gets his
second of the year and the padres take a
7-0 lead don't you just love this game
of baseball i'll tell you what it'll
make you scratch your head it'll give
you ulcers it'll make you happy it'll
bring it to your knees austin hedges is
all over a fastball launch angle bullpen
bound good for austin all right oh
dornow he popped up in the second inning
rangers down seven nothing
and odor with a big swing sends this one
out to the alley right field that one's
down and against the wall gallows in
solac right behind him a two-run double
for odor
and the rangers have broken through on
davies it's seven to two couple men on
and now for the heart of the order joey
gallo
02.
joey hits his ball hard to center field
grisham going back and that's over his
head and up against the wall and it's
still rolling
santana is in
frazier to third
it's a double for joey gallo in a 7-3
game this ball had some carry on it off
the bat
some really good base running here by
the rangers it's a tough one san diego's
lead is cut to 7-3 on a booming double
by throws audrey's in business trying to
add on here in the seventh inning
1-0 is laced towards the gap in left
center field that ball is back and it is
gone fernando tatis junior in a line
drive three-run home run
get out of here in a hurry he's into
double figures and home runs that's
number 10 of the season
and the padres jump on top 10-3
i tell you what if you've got any
laundry out there you want to hang you
could have hung it on this thing right
here oh my goodness gracious no launch
angle 17 degrees on the launch angle
that's a real great opportunity for
junior right here
this is in the air to right field back
it goes nando has done it again fernando
tatis jr a grand slam and the padres go
on top 14-3
two home runs seven rbis for fernando
tatis jr
unbelievable tatis has just hit a grand
slam his second home run of the night
padres have a 14-3 lead this kid is some
kind of special from seoul
2-1 pitch this one on the ground
near second a quick flip for one on the
first and that one gets passed and all
the way to the screen in front of the
dugout and it allows danny santana to
score 14 to 4. luis perdomo who pitched
the eight back out there to pitch the
ninth inning heinemann got him for the
first time and grounding one to
shortstop kronenworth will go to second
for the fourth sound that will end this
ball game and a victory for the padres
and a huge night for fernando tati's
junior a three-run home run a grand slam
it all adds up to a 14-4 padres victory
in game one of the series